I'm not sure how different they are
actually because I've been practicing 35
years I mean I as a feminist I believe a
legal social political and economic
equality for women with men I often say
if you're not a feminist then you're a
bigot I mean there is nothing in-between
it's like being pregnant you either are
pregnant or you're not what else is
there there is no in-between
so either you are for first class as a
citizenship that means you're a feminist
or you're for second-class citizenship
for women which means to me you're a
bigot or you're in support of
subordination of women instead of full
equality full partnership for women in
each and every aspect of life so
feminism is about improving the
condition and status of women and
vindicating their rights
conservatives usually say look how far
you've come looking back to where you
are now
isn't that great progress but as a
progressive person I don't look to see
where we've come from I look to where we
should be and so now I don't think we've
come far enough because I'm judging by
the gold standard and that is equality
we should be at the level of equality
politically economically legally
emotionally socially we're not there and
so we still have a long long way to go
and we need more activism legally
politically in the streets everywhere to
make this happen as I say no one ever
gave us our rights including the right
to vote we had to fight to win it
well I don't think there's revolution I
do think it's evolution but it's not
going to happen unless women stand up
and demand it it's as simple as that
there's no one gives up power without a
struggle and there is a huge struggle
going on for power and for control over
women's lives so I would like to think
that both my daughter and my
granddaughter will enjoy equality in
their lifetimes I'm sure that I will not
in my lifetime but it's not going to
happen unless women demand it and unless
our daughters say this is what we have a
right to and we are going to force the
rights we have and we are going to
demand more rights and we're not going
to be satisfied until we win those
rights that's how change is won and
there are just so many women and girls
around the world who do not yet enjoy
that equal educational opportunity some
of them can't get any educational
opportunity at all do not enjoy an
employment opportunity do not I mean
they are just living desperate lives and
some of them are being trafficked as sex
slaves and exploited in sweatshops
some of them are literally prisoners in
their own home we have so much more work
to do the work really has just begun